what is subtext well subtext is critical
also to writing and acting but it's
really what's not spoken it's what's
really happening in the scene what
someone's really feeling thinking but
they're saying something else covering
it up and you know really as a director
you're trying to direct the subtext in a
scene
so it's about identifying what that
subtext is
and and that's what the actors are you
know playing
uh and the words are they're saying
you're almost there not that there's a
peripheralist but that's not really
what's going on in the scene what
they're saying it's what they're
thinking and feeling underneath
in fact if I may digress a little bit I
I just did a short film last year in
Paris a little spy Thriller a lot of fun
and I wanted to shoot it in French
because I just didn't want to have
French people speaking English with
accents should be ridiculous yeah so we
were going to subtitle it and shoot it
in French I don't speak French
so I had to learn a little bit of it uh
phonetically just so I could kind of get
recognize the words my French producer
of course was bilingual so he would help
me when the actors strayed
but the truth is it didn't matter
because I wasn't directing the words I
was directing what they were their
behavior and what was behind those words
and that's why I was I think I was able
to pull it off because I just wasn't
worried about it that and the fact that
it wasn't that much dialogue but uh so
it really is important to know what the
character's intentions are in the scene
how they're being thwarted
um what they're really what's going on
underneath everything that's subtext
so even if you turn the sound down you
could still kind of feel it from the
bottom ideally in fact I I like to do an
exercise with students from time to time
when I sometimes do classes on working
with actors and directing actors and I I
get a sample scene
of two characters having lunch
and I had them memorize the scene I
don't give them any notes but I said you
memorize the scene so when you come in
tomorrow you're off book and ready to do
it and so they come into the class and
we confirm we've never spoken about the
scene we haven't talked about it nothing
so I had them just play the scene first
with no direction at all whatsoever
and it's like a financing then I'll say
okay so here now
um you were late for this lunch again
and you're the same partner you are so
fed up with this person being late that
you want to just kill them you feel
disrespected you feel you know and you
on the other hand you feel like this
person always judging you and that and
so we didn't change a word of dialogue
or nothing else at all and they came in
and played this scene again completely
different scene and we kept doing that
with different before you know four or
five different permutations on on what's
the subtext of the scene is it was a
great way to illustrate for these
students that wow you know it really is
about the subtlety the Nuance of
behavior the body language
and you can add a different meaning to
any scene
and do you let the other party know the
other actor know the intention or do you
do it in secret well and this it's a
good idea to do that in this case I let
them both know because it was instructed
for the students I wanted them to hear
it but I have had moments where I've
been directing where I've held something
back from one actor
and given the information to another
actor not in a
anything that's damaging or Menace or
anything like that you know there are
other times where I've had two stars in
a scene and I felt like you're the one
star was a little bit intimidated by
this slightly bigger star in the scene
with and uh I could just tell in the
scene that that he was
cowering just a little bit and and that
wasn't really true for his character his
character had to be had to stand up to
this guy
and so I just took him aside you know
afterward between tanks and I just said
you know don't let him take the scene
away from you
and he instantly got it you know and
then it was great then it was like fire
because you know and so now that kind of
train you know they're really in the
scene together so sometimes you know
withholding a little bit and giving
extra information to somebody else's you
know can be helpful what if a scene
doesn't have any subtext that is not a
scene it's not shootable it's not
actable
and and you know you at least have to be
able to put a subtext in it you know and
I can't actually I can't even imagine a
scene uh I mean a writer could have
written a scene without some things
because they're just unconscious or just
working on a very surface level
but anybody can any director or actor
can take a scene and insert something
it's the simplest thing in the world you
know what what just happened to me right
before I entered the scene
what am I worried about you know I've
got a pain in my rib that I'm really
worried about and I'm afraid to go to
the doctor about it these are things are
never spoken in the scene but they're
going to inform how the scene is played
uh so there's always got to be got to be
subjects no such thing as no subjects
and even if it's just one actor in a
room and no one else enters that room
yeah yeah it's still about what's you
know what's really going on
uh with this person what does he really
want
how does the director help an actor
convey subtext so if I'm an actor in a
scene and maybe it's another you know
someone's late and they're always late
maybe it's my sister and they've always
gotten away with being irresponsible and
I've always had to be the responsible
one how are you helping me convey
subtext to this late sister that's
she's not there and yeah I'm mad we've
got reservations I've got to be back at
work right right you know it's it's
really about body language uh and I feel
like it's dangerous for me
try to give them a specific thing to do
a behavioral thing to do because it's I
don't want them to indicate I don't want
them to
to feel like they're going to imitate me
you know some reason why I would I would
never give a line reading unless some
ask for it and oftentimes an actor will
ask me you know just just tell me how do
you hear it yeah but other than that I
would never give a library and I'm very
hesitant to give too much of a specific
you know behavioral thing but I'll just
try to make it attitudinal you know how
do you feel when this happens last time
this happened you know how does it make
you feel and I just try to get them to
summon their own feeling not to try to
give them one but but to try to just
have them summon their own experience
and everyone knows what it's like to be
annoyed you know so I just try to
encourage them to bring it from within
just like I would a writer or anyone
else so yeah so you'd be more asking me
as the actor how is this making you feel
um instead of like telling me the tone
right I would just say you know just the
third time it's the third time this week
this has happened
you know I don't know I don't think she
respects you yeah and that usually will
sir you'll give some sort of honest
you know so instead he's saying look tap
your foot look at your watch you know
that's it's you know nobody wants to
hear that you're sure and no one wants
to walk into a lunch like that either
right yeah yeah